la menace est réelle cette guerre
barbare se conduit sous menace nucléaire
depuis le 24 février et ça fait 8 mois
on a eu des phases dans cette guerre où
le cette utilisation était tout à fait
possible en particulier quand les Russes
ont reculé derrière Kef au début du mois
de mars ensuite la chose était
improbable maintenant elle redevient
véritablement possible il est clair que
Poutine n'acceptera pas de perdre il ne
perdra pas en conservant des atouts
qu'il pourrait jouer donc s'il en vient
être complètement acculé à perdre sur le
terrain il n'est pas du tout impossible
qu'il utilise ses armes c'est dans la
doctrine militaire et politique russe
alors que disent des renseignements
américains c'est ça qui est encore
inquiété
davantage aujourd'hui avec ces
renseignements ils disent quoi alors les
renseignements disent que pour l'instant
ils n'ont pas vu ils n'ont pas eu de
signes mais ils disent aussi qu'ils ne
sont pas absolument sûr de voir quand
les armes commenceront à se
prépositionner pour tirer il y a des
armes dont on verrait immédiatement
qu'elles vont être utilisées ce sont les
armes nucléaires stratégiques qui sont
des armes considérables on voit les
armes nucléaires tactiques sont des
armes du champ de bataille qu'on
dissimule beaucoup plus facilement il
n'est pas du tout évident qu'on perçoit
la préparation de leur mise en œuvre
avant qu'elle soit utilisée alors pour
les téléspectateurs pour nous ici sur on
parle donc de bombe nucléaires voilà
c'est sur ces termes la Russie elle
pourrait perdre la guerre c'est pour ça
que vous pensez que c'est c'est voilà
c'est ça peut arriver alors d'abord je
voudrais vous dire que il y a les armes
et le langage autour des arbres ce qu'on
sait là est-ce que c'est des bruits des
des fuites organisées ou pas si vous
voulez encore c'est parce qu'il y a tout
un langage nucléaire ce qu'on peut
vouloir dire aussi ce que peuvent
vouloir dire les Russes c'est qu'on on
ouvre cette menace de manière à faire
peur aux Américains faire peur aux
Américains faire peur aux citoyens
américains aux citoyens europ etc donc
c'est simplement peut-être un langage
maintenant à votre question est la
Russie peut-elle perdre ou non cette
guerre il est évident qu'elle peut la
perdre et que comme Monsieur Poutine
n'acceptera pas de la perdre encore une
fois il est il n'est pas probable mais
il est possible qu'il utilise ses armes
ce serait quoi les effets d'une bombe
nucléaire sur l'Ukraine alors on fait ce
qu'on veut je dirais avec une bombe
nucléaire là je parle des petits bombes
nucléaires il y a pas véritablement de
petite bombe nucléaire parce que une
petite bombe nucléaire c'est presque
celle d'Hiroshima une Nagasaki
bon et donc on peut faire si vous tirez
une arme nucléaire dans un désert vous
ne pouvez personne si vous tirez une
arme nucléaire sur l'île au serpent dont
on a beaucoup parlé vous ne pouvez
personne si vous tirez la même arme
nucléaire à la bonne hauteur au-dessus
de KEF vous tuez 200000 personnes donc
il est possible si vous voulez que le
président Poutine décide il va choisir
ce qu'il veut faire il peut d'abord dire
au monde attention je suis réellement
fou et je peux utiliser ces armes auquel
cas il les utilisera sans s'en tuer dans
un endroit il y aura peu de dégâts pour
dire croyez en moi croyez en ma folie
très fort ou alors il peut décider
d'aller au-delà ce qui est d'aller
au-delà donc de dire je veux 100 morts
1000 morts mille morts ou 200000 morts
puisque vous allez choisir finalement
c'est une arme nucléaire dite tactique
c'est incroyable mais dont les effets
sont beaucoup plus stratégiques et
politiques que tactique si vous voulez
il ne peut pas utiliser ses armes sur le
front parce qu'il tuerait autant de
soldats russes que de soldats ukrainien
donc il en attendra un résultat
stratégique pour geler la situation pour
faire peur pour faire cesser ce conflit
que probablement il est en train de
perdre est-ce que comme certains le
pense ce serait le début d'un conflit
mondial ça c'est
pas forcément ah oui pas forcément la
question est comment comment répondre
l'Ukraine ne peut pas répondre au même
niveau parce qu'elle n'a pas l'arme
nucléaire qui pourrait répondre c'est
les pays dotés de l'Occident la France
les États-Unis l'Angleterre la France la
France répondra pas
vous savez la doctrine est très claire
lactine est très claire c'est-à-dire que
en France comme aux États-Unis l'arme
atomique est utilisée quand les intérêts
vitaux de la nation sont menacées c'est
ça est-ce qu'on estimera si une bombe
nucléaire tombe sur l'île aux serpent au
milieu l'Ukraine que les intérêts de la
France sont menacés c'est au président
Macron doit aussi des et c'est au
président Biden dans décider moi je n'en
sais un chacun peut répondre à la
question ce qui est clair c'est que si
une réponse nucléaire était apportée par
un des pays dotés des pays occidental
dotés alors là on mettrait le pied dans
un engrenage dont les résultats
pourraient être absolument
catastrophique pour le monde entier
aujourd'hui on a des raisons d'être
inquiets ou pas du tout écouter je crois
qu'il faut être fait parce qu'il faut
arrêter cette guerre il faut que
Monsieur Poutine arrête et qu'il rende
ce qu'il a volé à l'Ukraine mais en même
temps il faut être responsable il faut
être raisonnable donc une situation une
position ferme déterminée mais à la fois
responsable pour le monde entier puisque
ça peut se terminer extrêmement mal
alors ce serait quoi une position
responsable parce que c'est on ne peut
pas pousser monsieur Poutine jusqu'à
l'utilisation de ces arbres alors
comment faire je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas on voit bien que par exemple
aller frapper Moscou ou aller frapper à
l'intérieur du du territoire russe là
serait la culé et probablement cela
entraînerait une réponse déraisonnable
l'important c'est que cette guerre
s'arrête sans aller au-delà de ce qui
est raisonnable de faire à qui l'on
jugeait c'est à nos gouvernements ce qui
est important quand on fait la guerre il
faut qu'elle soit conduite avec
ils ont beaucoup plus qu'avec passion
évidemment l'esprit combattant est tout
à fait important pour ceux qui
conduisent ailleurs mais celui qui se
laisse prendre par son esprit combattant
alors là devient extrêmement dangereux
et cette fois-ci pour la planète entière
donc raison beaucoup plus que patient
fermeté et
caractère raisonnable de la de la de
l'utilisation de la force